[Music]
please welcome everybody Ike Baron Holtz
Ike
[Applause]
[Music]
Barz just stay like this for 12
minutes so I understand you're on The
Mindy Project yeah it's been pretty
exciting pretty exciting season
cool yeah is is that a real hospital no
it's actually a set at Universal Studios
oh Orlando Florida no no no right across
Barum oh my yeah oh I was thinking the
one with the rides no no no there's
there's an amusement park portion of it
but that's totally separate common
mistake Pete did you see the Matrix uh
only the
sequels I was I was lost I was lost did
you watch Lost yes the series yes yes
nice they were all in
purgatory oh the whole time is that what
it
was
right bit hey put me
right solid bit I'm glad you're on the
show because uh people do think we're
the same person yeah I know I I met you
a couple days ago and we talked about
this yeah and I was like people come up
to me all the time and say you're great
on the mini project so much so that I
just say thank you now that's I
appreciate that that's good I go thanks
people people come to me like I I saw
you man at the Improv man you killed
yeah and I'm like that's not me that's
Pete Holmes oh you go honest yeah I do
because I don't want to no go ahead
really it's like that change up movie
cuz you you're married and have kids you
could be you could be me and just go
home alone and eat
soup so I'm glad I'm glad we're being on
camera at the same time and proving to
America once and for all we are separate
human beings we're separate human beings
trap someone though though but
butes I smell bad you said it I got you
you look so stupid just
now I did get sweaty dancing
earlier is this The
Mentalist I'm so wasted I'm so
horny
I I talked to a young man in the crowd
who was very horny oh really yeah he's
17 so that oh my God he's a a boner he's
a boner wearing shoes yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're a living boner
every woman you see you could see Janet
Reno you're I want to have sex with her
right now yeah yeah it's a very
confusing time the good thing is that
that only lasts until you're like 75
that's really I when I was a kid when I
was his age I used to worry that at some
point I would have to I don't know why
God would tell me you have to apologize
to everyone you've ever thought about
while masturbating oh my God that's like
Schindler's List I can't well no no not
because they're
Jewish because it's a long list of
thousands of people you could have said
Santa's
list but you went right to the Holocaust
the two whitest what are you I'm Jewish
though oh you're Jewish yeah so I get to
get out of jail free card those of you
who laughed at that joke you're
anti-semitic and your names are being
written down on the Hollywood blog
on the Hollywood blog Hollywood blog you
uh you were on Matt TV and I know you do
some Impressions and I I've been told uh
you do a wonderful Bane Bane from Batman
Bane from Batman yes and I you do a
great Batman
well I like the turn this is taken yes I
I I would imagine those guys together
when they're not fighting you you're
setting it up like we planned it but we
we really really did now I feel like the
expectation is like they're going to do
a duet
no no no no you're just going to hear
the voices and then you're going to go
uh where do we park what if it's what if
it's um what if it's Batman and Bane uh
at Buffalo Wild Wings
okay are you thinking boneless or with
bones you got to go
boneless I should do this
ooh ooh ooh ooh they have they have
waffle
fries I like the waffle fries shuffles
in the morning fries in the
lunchtime Seinfeld Batman so so maybe
maybe maybe we we get 20 wings and some
awful fries and maybe we share a
dessert now you have my permission for
fries
it's so
[Applause]
[Music]
stupid